hier ist sie wieder die Show mit Preisen
genauer mit Hammerpreisen z.B dieser CD
von fah und dieser Power Edition seines
neuen Albums Invictus und nur bei uns
hier mit
fahtautogramm ja warum ich mir hier den
Mund fusselig Rede das Schuld ich
unserem Sponsor vielen Dank dafür aber
jetzt geht es auch schon los und fahrt
erklärt euch haklein was ihr machen
müsst damit ihr einen dieser
sensationellen Preise gewinnen könnt bis
dann bleibt dran
jetzt kommt etwas ganz Besonderes nicht
nur eine ganz normale CD gibt's hier zu
gewinnen der Trostpreis das ist der
Trostpreis den es gibt das ist die
Standardversion vom Album mit 16
liderern aber für die ganz flinken unter
den klickum
Klicks klickom Zuschauern habe ich mir
etwas einfallen lassen und zwar kriegt
ihr dieses Fanpaket bzw die Power
Edition die es zum Album gab beinhaltet
ein T-Shirt und zwei CDs also alle 22
Songs was Ihr dafür beantworten mss ist
eigentlich ganz easy ihr müsst sagen mir
sagen können bzw dem netten Christoph
Christopher müsst ihr sagen können
wann fängt die invctus Tour an und wann
genau hört sie auf die beiden Daten
brauchen wir richtig und ich gebe euch
einen kleinen Tipp damit es nicht allzu
schwer weil ich sei weiß ja ihr seid
sehr bequeme Leute schaut doch einfach
mal auf
www.fahruhpot.de vorbei und gewinnt
dieses Powerpaket was ich jetzt für den
Gewinner schon mal ein bisschen
unterzeichnen werde weil das ist nämlich
auch noch das sensationelle es ist
unterzeichnet ähm und ihr müsst das
ganze mailen an
klicksum@gmail.com ist auch noch mal in
Anmerkung unten genannt und im Infotext
und das erste Datum und das letzte Datum
muss genannt werden
in der Mail und dann ist eigentlich
alles Gerit alles getan super danke dir
vielmals
gerne